and welcome to Hannity so we had two
leading Governors from two major states
with two vastly different ideologies
they just squared off right here on the
show Hannity and last night's explosive
and informative red state blue State
debate between Florida Governor Ronda
santis California governor Gavin Nome it
did not disappoint take a
look California does have freedoms uh
that some people don't uh the other
states don't you have the freedom to
defecate in public in California you
have the freedom to pitch a on Sunset
Boulevard you have the freedom to create
a homeless encampment under a freeway
and even light it on fire I love the
Rand on freedom I mean here's a guy
who's criminalizing teachers
criminalizing doctors criminalizing
Librarians and criminalizing women that
seek their reproductive care you're
making it harder to vote you're Banning
books I mean spare me this notion of
Freedom you almost have to try to mess
California up that's what Gavin Newsome
has done since he's been Governor you in
particular Ron are on a Banning binge a
cultural Purge and intimidating and
humiliating people you disagree with
he's very good at spinning these these
tals he's good at at being slick and
slippery he'll he'll tell a blizzard of
lies to be able to try to mass the
failures the fact he's running away from
his record he's running away from the
fact we do count Gavin's in-laws as some
of the people that have fled California
um and come to the State of Florida it's
about the United States of America I
thought this guy was running for
president of the United States you're
running for running for a
third you will not admit it I'm the only
guy here that's a border state Governor
you're trolling folks and trying to find
migrants to play political games try to
get some news intention so you can out
Trump trump and by the way how's that
going for you Ron try to put lipstick on
that pig but the fact of the matter is
he has failed the people I can handle it
I'm used to bully you're nothing but a
bully understand that intimidating and
humiliating people that's your
calling all right coming up we're going
to get reaction and Analysis from both
sides of the aisle also new king or
Senator Ram Paul tonight and stay tuned
we have a major announcement at the end
of the program spoiler alert we have
another Big Show in the works and it
will happen next week all right unlike
the other networks we are not afraid of
a spirited debate now none of this would
have been possible without both Governor
Nome Governor DeSantis they both deserve
a lot of credit and they seem to really
enjoy the opportunity uh both thank me
after the debate and Governor New
tweeted out how what a good time he had
and and wanted to go longer and let's be
honest there was only one clear-cut
loser if we're going to look at last
night's debate objectively that'd be
President Joe Biden here's the reality
Joe Biden could never come on this
program for a debate like last night
because he's not mentally capable now
think about this look I really don't
believe Joe Biden could be a Wallmart or
a Target greeter okay if you shop like I
do do you ever walk in on Walmart or a
Target anyway there are these wonderful
kind amazing helpful often retired
people that will greet you and say
welcome to Walmart welcome to Target uh
what might you be looking for they'll
help you find it they'll tell you where
the department is that you're looking
for I like that CU When I go to a store
I like to go in I like to get out now I
don't think Joe would be able to
remember where the Departments are at 81
years of age in steep cognitive decline
Biden's having a hard time talking
walking and even staying awake his
hearing's not good his vision's terrible
the font size on his teleprompter is
gigantic he's not fit to serve he should
definitely not be running for reelection
in fact he is one major trip and fall
away from ending his campaign and based
on last night we know the Democratic
party has a much better option who can
walk and talk and form sentences and
debate and speak eloquently about the
liberal issues that they're passionate
about and I've been warning conservative
atives and Republicans to watch out for
potential replacements for Joe and Gavin
Nome like it or not would be on the
short list I've been warning people now
Nome does have one big problem he's the
governor of California the golden state
has a lot of problems now maybe in
fairness it's not all of Governor nome's
fault but after more than a decade of
single party Democratic rule it's
citizens are leaving the state in droves
they are leaving with their feet and
their money and by the way California it
should never struggle it has more
natural resources than any other state
in the country I lived there 5 years it
is a beautiful state they have yearr
agriculture the best wine growing region
in the entire world Silicon Valley they
have Hollywood Disney it's also a major
private equity and financial Hub with
some of the largest International ports
in the entire world it is a gateway to
Asia but now California's population it
is shrinking and shrinking dramatically
and while the US population grows every
single year Well California is one of
the only States in history with negative
growth now just three states California
New York and Illinois had a net loss of
more than 100,000 people in the Years
2021 and 2022 one big question the cost
of living the state's taxes they are
among the highest in the country a
whopping 133% top marginal rate if
you're a married couple in California
you make $84,000 a year you are taxed
your income tax rate is 6% that is a ton
it's expensive to live in California in
Florida income taxes are zero not nobody
pays income taxes the state regulations
are also extreme when it comes to
California Housing costs through the
roof it's the homeless population it is
the highest in the country crime is also
a massive problem in California the
violent crime rate in the state is
double the rate of Florida significantly
higher than the national average these
are real problems facing the citizens in
California it is some of the most
extreme at the time covid policies in
the country it it's kids they were kept
out of schools longer than most other
states and yet this is an interesting
fact when you think about the different
approaches to co the covid death rate in
California was similar to Florida's
according to the CDC and interestingly
both below the national average now the
bottom people are leaving California uh
for a reason the bottom line here it's a
hard place to live especially for middle
class Americans California's government
it has stifled development raised taxes
increased costs failing to maintain
important infrastructure like the
electric grid and the state has also
dropped the ball when it comes to Public
Safety but this is not the result of
incompetency instead these problems are
caused by ideology
California can be turned around and
sadly a lot of these policies are driven
by what I call the climate alarmist
religious cult and these woke social
justice Warriors out there California
has thrown reason and logic too often to
the wind in order to appease the
emotions of far-left ideologues and now
the numbers speak for themselves but
despite all of this everyone on Earth
knows that Gavin Newsome would be a
democratic candid better Democratic
candidate than Joe Biden
uh now will Joe Biden step aside uh will
vice president Harris step aside because
he only you know in the case of Joe he
seems to only care about himself hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else